الله
[موسيقى]
اكبر دوله نوويه يقف وراءها اقوياء العالم
واغنياء لكنها رخوه
كذلك فلا يكاد يمسها الضر حتى يعيد كثير
من مواطنيها التفكير في فكره وجودها اصلا
مفكرين في الرحيل هذه الرخاوه تفسر تقاطر
الوفود لتاكيد الدعم العسكري والنفسي
فواشنطن ارسلت حاملتي طائرات والفي جندي
مع كميات هائله من الذخائر والر بايدن في
طريقه الى تل ابيب اما وزير خارجيته
فزارها مرتين في ايام وماكرون ومستشار
المانيا ورئيس وزراء بريطانيا وغيرهم في
طريقهم لتاكيد
المسانده كل هذا من اجل اشتباك عابر مع
شبان قادمين من تحت هذه الرقعه المحاصره
منذ 16 عاما اكبر سجن مفتوح على ظهر الارض
حسب المنظمات
الحقوقيه ترجع هذه الرخاوه النفسيه الى
معضله اسرائيل مع الجغرافيا والتاريخ
فالناظر الى الخريطه يفهم المازق الابدي
الذي تعانيه البحر امامها والعرب وراءها
والضعيف لا يظل ضعيفا ابدا يحاصرها العرب
المطعمون بالشتات الفلسطيني فهذه لبنان
وسوريا شمالا وتلك الاردن شرقا ومن الجنوب
يرقبها اكثر من 100 مليون مصري تمتلئ
ذاكرتهم التاريخيه بمحاربه الغزاه من حطين
الى السادس من اكتوبر وفي خاصرتها تتقلب
غزه والضفه وفلسطيني
48 الما
مزمنا هذه الحقائق الجغرافيه كابوس ابدي
في اذهان قاده
اسرائيل هذه اسرائيل دوله صغيره محاصره
بعالم عربي معاد لها لكن يجب ان تفهموا ان
الفلسطينيين يمثلون 2 بالم فقط من العرب
لكنهم يراهنون على ذلك العالم العربي
الكبير ليتك لب على اسرائيل ويخنقها ويفكك
هذ لاسرائيل مشكله مع التاريخ كذلك فقد
ولدت والعالم ينفض يديه من فكره الاستعمار
والامبراطوريات تطوي اعلامها وتغادر اماكن
نفوذها مجلده بالعار وقد تكون معضلته في
صلابه ضحاياها كذلك اقسم بالله ماهز عرف
في وحياه الله ما هز شعره حسبي الله ونعم
الوك هذا اللي بقدر اقول عليه فالصمت الذي
تتحلى به المقاومه وحاضنتها الشعبيه يربك
الموازين الماديه التي تخطط لها دوله
الاحتلال فالشجاع الواقفه وراء هذه
المشاهد عمله نادره في عالم تتكو اقوى
جيوشه على المرتزقه من بلاك وتر الى فاجنر
وهي جيوش تملك كل اسباب القوه الماديه
لكنها قد تفتق احيانا الى الفرد المندفع
تضحيه واقدام وهي حقيقه تجعل كثيرا من تلك
الجيوش تعرف كيف تقتل لكنها لا تحسن كيف
تقاتل